quelle est la différence entre un mec
pour y est un mec bien qui fait des
trucs pourris où est la frontière entre
un mensonge innocent et le mal absolu
pas de quartier je veux que tu leur
arrachent les vieux je t'ai parlé lui
john tu joues est un vrai génie
j'aimerais beaucoup connaître ta
stratégie messieurs et si on faisait de
l'argent neuf
le bbc
la seule différence entre les
investissements à haut risque et une
pyramide de ponzi
c'est le résultat cette affaire va
rapporter un quart de milliard de
dollars je vis ne seront plus jamais les
mêmes
on va être milliardaire
il a déjà conduit une voiture neuve ce
bolide vaut plus cher que mon appart
non
tu es un peu bordélique jo tu avais
dépenses courantes avec les fentes et au
courant du rouge au vert de wall street
tu crois vraiment qu'on peut faire
fortune sans tricher il est où le pognon
l'argent n'existait pas vraiment
run levin m'a mis sur la paille comment
je dois beaucoup d'argent à beaucoup de
monde je dois absolument les rembourser
si le bbc se casse la figure
toute notre comptabilité de l'année
écoulée va passer sous le microscope du
fisc de la sc du fbi y aille
comment vous l'obligent riez à nous
rendre notre fric j'ai compris ce jour
là que parfois la vérité et le mensonge
idéal au 8 mai du scotch sur la bouche
pour pas l'entendre crier
viléo rendent les vignes qu'est ce
qu'elle vaut rien n'est fait
il n'y a plus qu'une seule chose à faire
sauver les meubles et en finir
tu culpabilises pas du tout